everything you've said you're saying
today is kind of I don't really
articulate is My Philosophy like I think
the smartest people in the room are the
people who know what they don't know you
know and people who know what they who
think they know that's how I got
to a lot of things that I got was I
always knew what I sucked at so I didn't
have to waste time
like when I play drums as much as I love
playing drums when I would go to a music
store I always tell this story I would
go in and I would see some kid half my
age sit down at the drums and pick up a
guitar and you could see he he was
expressing himself already he had it and
I was like like I was trying to figure
out what he was doing I just knew I was
just like you you enjoy drums you're a
fan of music but you are not a musician
this is not your calling so I just kept
moving around I'm like all right suck at
that [__] that do you really think you
suck at that or you didn't put your time
into it like you didn't have as much
like you you're a fan of drums I mean I
think that I could have gotten to like
you know being a wedding band maybe a
cover band I mean if I played enough I
have enough of an ability that I I could
sound all right but like I gotta be
honest with one of my favorite things
ever is when you just hear a
professional drummer just sit down on a
kit just to hear what they sound like
this there is a different sound when a
professional drummer who's your favorite
drummer in the world oh God that's I
can't answer that there's just there's
so many there's just so many
um and there's just so many different
types of music
that um oh God you're a metal band fan
though I know but I I like uh like
you know I I love I saw Dave Grohl live
when he was with um
uh Them Crooked vultures John Theodore I
saw him with Queens of the Stone Age
uh Steve Jordan he was the Letterman
drummer and played in Keith Richards
band now he's in the stones was a huge
one for me
uh Vinnie Paul Alex Van Halen Phil Rudd
Elvin Jones uh uh Tony Williams you're
just gonna name everyone yeah you're
just gonna because they all have like
and then what's fun is trying to see how
they all fit in the puzzle of like oh
you know trying to guess who you know
listened to who or whatever so it's kind
of drumming I would imagine I don't know
a lot about music and and drumming but I
would imagine it's like comedy you know
you could mention all the different
comedians but no two comedians are alike
they have that Rhythm they have their
sense of humor they have their
uniqueness and the way you're describing
that there's just a lot in this then
there's the mainstream accessible ones
and then there's the Comics comic ones
and then there's the guys who are like
you know there's just so many it's just
like like with music like every uh
anybody who doesn't play drums he knows
Keith Moon knows John Bonham knows like
those those main guys but then you get
people into music and then drummers
drummers and it's sort of like this
whole uh like pyramid of stuff and all
of them
are uh necessary
you know what I mean like have you got
this I like pop music and all that [__]
all of that stuff is it's all necessary
have you got the opportunity to sit in
with a band that you like and drum with
a band that you like
uh yeah I've set in with people that I
like I wasn't necessarily in the band
but yeah who did you play with and is it
recorded
uh yeah I'll I'll tell you one of the
crazier ones was I got to play with Duff
and Slash from Guns and Roses and I
didn't know it was gonna happen is that
on YouTube right now it's somewhere out
there yeah so let's look at it don't
play that Jesus Christ why because I
don't want to watch myself
because I just look like a dad
and a [__] Make-a-Wish
camping slash and Dave Kushner and
Frankie Perez how did that come to be
Dave Kushner uh who's in Velvet Revolver
and is now an incredible composer
uh for film and television he composed
everything for f is for family
um
um your Netflix show yes the cartoon
that I did so he is a really big-hearted
guy a big family guy like I'm really
good friends with him and and like I've
become he's one of those people I became
friends about became a better person
because I like how he lives his life you
know so he goes hey you know he goes my
my kids school they go to were doing
like a fundraiser so I'm going to put
together a band
and it was like there was the rehearsal
band he didn't let me know Duff and
slash were coming that was the joke so I
was going to play Highway to Hell right
AC DC song so he went up
in rehearse during the day and
everything went great and he goes all
right cool uh all right we'll we'll play
the song tonight I go okay fantastic so
I come back at night so it's my turn to
go up on drums and I'm thinking like I
was watching like
I remember I was late in the show and it
made no sense to me I was like why
wouldn't you get the stupid comic out of
the way early why would you put him way
late and like I remember the drummer was
was played with Blue Man Group he was a
[__] beast he was playing the who all
this Keith Moon [__] I'm like I can't
[__] why the [__] are they waiting so it
was like towards the end of the night
so they bring me up on stage and I was
so like I made sure I got on stage
before I even introduced me because I
was so like like just outside my element
and as I sit down I see the bass player
and the guitar player leaving
and then Duff and slash come up on stage
and I'm telling you like how big these
guys were
to me as a kid them standing there they
look like two redwoods I just remember
how big they were and Duff I had met one
other time I forget I think that was the
second time I met him and he's totally
cool he just sort of he's tall anyway
he's kind of leaned over so hey man
shook my hands
lashes there and I was like and Dave
just turned around laughed at me because
I had that look on my face of like what
the [__] and before I could even think
anything like slash starts because it
starts with the guitar
and like for the whole first verse I
couldn't feel my legs I couldn't believe
it
and uh it ended up going great I don't
think I [__] up and it ended
I got off and uh I got to meet the guys
it was fantastic and I remember it was
the most rock and roll thing I ever did
and then I immediately did the least
rock and roll thing was I got in my
Prius and I drove down the hill as I was
screaming
so I go to the store to go smoke a cigar
with some buddies of mine remember I got
out of the car and I'm literally flying
I couldn't believe it happened and uh I
get out of the car and the guy was uh
it goes uh he goes hey Bill you want to
do a spot I'm like no I don't I'm not
[__] that up I'm not gonna go up here
and then have a mediocrest I'm gonna
ride this as long as I can and I stayed
back there and like during the time I
was telling the comics that had happened
he sent me the video and they watched it
they were like what the [__] it was the
greatest night
on my life and I stayed up till like
three in the morning so at three in the
morning I get back in my Prius and as
I'm driving out I'm stopping looking for
traffic in this gorgeous woman
comes up to my passenger window and
knocks on the window I'm like oh could
my night get any better she's a big fan
right you think you're amusing don't you
no I put the window down and she stuck
her head and she was hammered she goes
Are You Enrique my Uber driver
and I I [__] like paused and she took
in my Irish features I'm not an Enrique
and I just go uh no no I'm not and she
laughed and I laughed and it was just
like boom I turned back into a pumpkin
and I was a dad and a [__] uh
actually I wanted dad before then was
there some guy in his 40s in a Prius and
I [__] laughed
the whole way home and I really took
that as like something from the universe
like all right come back down
you know Amazing Story don't be walking
around like we'll have in post we'll
have showed the audience this tape we
won't do it in front of you but yeah
what a great story what a great
moment and yeah so I've I've had uh uh
so I I've done that a couple of times
where I've gotten to play uh
you know with some just insane people
and uh yeah it doesn't make any sense
but it's happened
[Music]